[Musique]
depuis ample quasi peut rester juste une
wii
seulement une nuit
[Musique]
sérieux
il va beaucoup grandir ça dépend de
l'amour côté de 8 ans
clifford comment ça a pu arriver
[Musique]
c'est un gros chien ou chat trop mignon
vous n'êtes plus active que les
courriers prendre sa température coup sa
température qui les a dites vous
tu parles tu as pas caché
comment ça se fait qu'il ait pas encore
éclaté
à bayac a demandé
on ne voit que ça sur internet un chien
de trois mètres de haut en plein
manhattan ça ne peut pas être frères
devront 25000 dollars de récompense pour
la capture du grand charles les gens
n'aiment pas ce qui est différent
il n'existe aucun charme lui par qui
soit comme toi qu'est ce qu'il fait je
crois qu'ils essaient de faire péter
[Musique]
rempli quoi qu'on aille le savez bien
t'es sérieux là
imagine que tu entends quelqu'un qui est
tellement plein d'amour
côté tu te sens capable de tout ça sur
m'a sauvé la vie
toutes les portes du quartier métissé
conduire et à revendiquer
je vais puni pour la ville tous les deux
à mon avis
ils mangent pas bonnes a dit ben est un
animal je parlais de gi oh
[Musique]